The vertex of this parabola is at the point 1 comma 2. Great work if you found
this point. Keep in mind that this parabola is in the form x equals, so we know
that it's going to open either to the left or to the right. Since the a value
is a positive 1, we know that the graph opens to the right. Now this number is
important for the vertex its really these 2 numbers. Since this is a horizontal
parabola in the form x equals this number is the x coodinate of our vertex its
positive 1. To find the y coordinate of our vertex, we simply take our
binomial, and we set it equal to 0. So we'll have y minus 2 equals 0. Adding
two to both sides, we get y equals positive 2. This is the y-coordinate of our
vertex. And notice again how it matches the vertex form for a horizontal
parabola. This is h and this is k, 1 comma 2. Our vertex.